I get a feeling there's gonna be a riot
I don't be the no because all right
welcome to save space would Sam Tripoli
why did I have to say my name that's
where welcome thanks for tuning in I
love them back in the States I'm back to
the podcast sorry couldnt do it on
monday to get back in time so we're
doing to hear happy Thanksgiving
everybody who's listing I hope you get
this before the holiday if not you
listen to it after the holiday thank you
so much I appreciate everything the
years flown everybody's ready for 2017 I
don't know if it's necessarily going to
be better let's hope put out the
positive energy dude put it out there
2017 be fun be festive full of love but
thank you for tuning I just got to give
a shout out real quick to uh Canada I
love you there's nothing about can I
rely well real quick I'm going to get
into all my dates next ah next tuesday
night thatha tours are back we got
Brandon shabb Bert Kreischer ah who else
dusting your elbow um David dearie
Vanessa Johnston myself and Mike Tully
gotta show tuesday night a p.m. if
you're in LA come to the show get weird
ok and then the following weekend i am
in chicago at the comedy bar the SEC the
first second and third so come and hang
out I'd love to see everybody haven't
played Chicago and forever I just can't
wait to freeze my balls off free might
freeze my balls off I can't wait I'm
very excited so it's going to be good
Aaron how are you good Aaron do you I
get weird when when
re makes weird comments about you your
wife and your future children a little
bit I get more weird when he pees and
bottles on camera is that what happened
the other day oh yeah he when I left
retest he piss in a bottle and a bottle
in a cup tried to get it on camera and I
he said no this is a Christian station
no I think there's there's youtube
regulations against it for sure peeing
in a bottle on camera yeah I respect
that that's my that's my opinion wide
Twitter's dying is because there's too
much porn on Twitter and there's too
many people retweet porn or maybe that's
just my feet you think that keep it
alive no i think that i think would the
adult films everybody loves porn they
just want it in its own weird place on
the site which brings me to my next
point hello Canada can is great man
Canada's [ __ ] great I love everything
about Canada I can't get there enough
it's one of those countries where you go
could I live here answer is yes it's too
cold oh it's too cold but the people are
pretty laid back man they get it the
truth is they just get it and there's a
lot of reasons why but like their most
conservative people are like would be
liberals in America they be completely
blue liberals they're so laid back and
cool I you know and I realized this the
other day when I was a day off eyes at
the mall do you know that they have
adult bookstores in malls in Canada no
that's that that's remember we thought
Spencer's of the mall was crazy because
we they had tit dice remember like whoa
and we'll go expenses ball I'm gonna get
one of those pens where you do it upside
down and you see titties that's when
titties were worth something that's when
they were worth up now just there's so
much how much lighter do you think the
internet would be if you got rid of all
the porn oh they're beach bar there be
four pages it could be four pages left
there's so much tits and ass on the
internet like why are people still angry
like you go to there's a [ __ ] there's
in this one
Remington mall there is three adult
bookstore stop one in a weird corner
quietly away three locate throughout the
malls so you don't to walk too far to
find what that's good you know I think
it's good at my nikes we get you yeah
you can get a Cinnabon and a butt plug
yeah one stop but that's gotta be the
last stop right yeah well you're not
gonna stop and grab like a 10 inch black
dong and then go to panda express and
get all the Chinese people they're
really insecure do you have to bring
your own bag or they still have plastic
they gotta give you dude everywhere else
is play dude if you think this law in LA
you know in California about plastic
bags is about the environment and not
about making a dime every time everybody
buys a purchase you're [ __ ] it's all
about making it there's no reason to
charge for like if you pay a dime for a
bag are you gonna take more care for
that bag all a little baby back he'll
just sit in the corner I'm gonna take
care of you I just thought they should
combine the two bills the condoms in
porn and the plastic bag like you gotta
[ __ ] with a plastic bag on your dick I
you know dude as much as I hate the idea
I respect that and I would watch guy
[ __ ] with what [ __ ] Ralph's bags
on his dick and the problem is those
dicks are so big they could actually
feel up yeah that it could mine wouldn't
even do Klaus might be like one of those
really shitty halloween costumes where
your mom puts like the bed [ __ ]
blanket on you and then puts a hole and
you're like all your ghosts that would
be my dick just a little ghost and a
[ __ ] back trying to scare [ __ ] it
wouldn't work but yeah they got up
bookstores over there they're pretty
laid back man they're pretty laid back
ah and you're like why why is Canada so
laid back I'll tell you for a couple
reasons one is there news the news there
is it's really maybe for them I didn't
watch a [ __ ] ton of it but I've traveled
the world and i love to watch news and i
just watched their news is for the most
part informative it's not and it's
uplifting it's not fear mongering like
we CN n is on a fear mongering [ __ ]
run right now like this is like the
Golden Age of fear-mongering for CNN
like did you see the new thing that they
like it's like they're combing mental
facilities looking for anybody that will
say anything [ __ ] nuts like Siemens
like hey hey we're getting crazy [ __ ]
they want to say some guys like our
Juice people get him and make up we're
live in five four three it's just like
that doesn't represent anybody except
for the small minority of people the
notion the notion that if you'll if you
voted for Trump you're automatically
erase this is going to be the downfall
of everything just because some people
voted for Trump because they did like
Hillary there's nothing to do with being
a racist or bigoted unlike you I'm gonna
get any more than that I'm gonna get
amor that little later but right now I
wanna stay focus uh I lost you on that
one I feel like I lost Sharon on that I
you know I think you may not necessarily
be outwardly racist but you're you you
think that everybody who voted for Trump
has a bit of racism in them yeah I mean
well most people do I beyond beyond the
acceptable level of bigotry which we all
have everybody has an acceptable level
of bigotry yeah there's a little bit of
like [ __ ] that everybody's tiny bit
xenophobic a tiny bit or whatever other
words they are out there xenophobia ah
isolationist maybe I don't know but
there is a a little bit everybody kind
of looks at anybody who is not their own
as a little with a up a smidget a
smidget of a suspect I think I what's
going on here but I think most people is
country I'd like I said like more people
voted for her then voted for him that's
three weeks on this we're still talking
about and if you don't think that the
cling camp and all them are behind
all this propaganda [ __ ] uh I think it's
a society we should all agree never the
Washington news again I'm into don't
watch don't watch CNN Fox CNN yeah are
you watching you watch I go Kent Canada
I go across the world man the news is
totally different I'm not saying there's
no propaganda going on but Siena anytime
Don Lemon opens his mouth it hot
propaganda garbage comes out how about
began to garbage it's just like what do
you it's just like how do you Don Lemon
I would love to a sour lemon how long
does it take for him to fall asleep
crying like how long does he cry at
night before he goes back because he
knows the [ __ ] he's doing is so [ __ ]
stupid but back to Canadians op Garnett
uh one of the listeners a punch-drunk
very nice guys I'm not going to try to
pronounce his last name I'm [ __ ]
horrible at it if you listen to podcast
you know I can't say names go ahead from
Winnipeg will call nicest guy huge huge
punch young fan buys us gifts all the
time like if it's our birthday will buy
us a jersey by his hats he came he
wanted to get out of of Canada he comes
down and he buys us three tickets to the
clipper game because he's a raptor fan
and so I was like that's cool I had a
bunch self I to do but I'm like this guy
flew in I'm gonna go with him and it
gotta be honest with you anytime I work
with fans and I don't want any fans to
take this wrong way but the monkey Todd
situation from way back the day which
was before you Aaron we had a guy he's
an he was a big fan eater now let's just
say he's a little off and it was like
made everybody uncomfortable and he's a
good guy he's just got conditions and
it's I his fault he's dealing with it
the best they can I don't hate him but
I'm just saying it was such a weird
situation that whenever anybody deals
with us I kind of go hey man what's
going on here so and when everybody hits
me up they want work may go are you
[ __ ] crazy Isom are you
job are you whack job do you do wacky
[ __ ] are you [ __ ] crazy person cuz I
don't want to deal with crazy I like
fans i love fans without fans you know
Fanus is just a short for abbreviation
of fanatic you don't get it but it's
like are you crazy just don't pick her
out thing with anybody I'm a pretty easy
guy I'll deal with anybody just don't be
a whack job and Garnett was he's a very
nice guy bus tickets so he he bought us
when he showed us where he was like hey
where's these tickets and they were like
high up and I was like okay I usually
don't do second row I don't do the high
the high area but I'll do it because I'm
very thankful that he would even come
down and buy his tickets I'll do it I'm
only joking I'll take any ticket I'll
sit high up with the Mexicans I don't
give a [ __ ] careful how you're holding
at hand what do you mean I'll thrown it
up yeah don't up like that is that it
now we're freezing frames now so my
somebody's freezing frames cuz I'm
talking about the high up nosebleed
seats and now I got people throwing
[ __ ] I'll Hitler's and everybody is
that all right listen dude I am the most
liberal I got an argument last night
with this guy I'm the most liberal doing
the world there's nothing about me that
is conservative now and if your
conservative you listen this I don't
worry I'll it's cool man you believe
what you want to believe it's when you
enact rules on other people that's why I
problem whatever you want believe in
believe in it there's nothing about me
that's conservative nothing ah you know
sometimes feminists drive me [ __ ]
nuts okay but I'm gonna be honest with
you I'm not worried about feminist cuz
once we get japanese sex robots i'm not
going to deal with this [ __ ] anymore
once i gotta [ __ ] robot do i got put up
with your [ __ ] hey go sleep on the bed
you know doesn't kick me the bed babe
bim bop 5,000 ok and guess what i just
got an upgrade for detachable [ __ ] ok
so keep running your mouth lady i was
talking about how women like women like
think guys want porno sex we don't want
porno sex men want bump dump go to sleep
sex that's what we want but you had to
start with this foreplay [ __ ] right they
have a cell with the foreplay
stuff and now we're like okay for place
so I gotta I gotta pay the bills mow the
lawn paint the house so I can fix the
cupboard somebody breaks in the house I
gotta fight them the boat goes down I
gotta go last and on top of that on top
I gotta eat your [ __ ] okay all right
guess it's getting the poop chute
tonight okay daddy's home so once we
have [ __ ] robots have to worry about all
this [ __ ] I really do think sex robots
and virtual reality porn is the only
hope for mankind let these [ __ ] poor
people dump in the [ __ ] robots all
day we need less people yep our Earth's
only hope is it's really pulling out
anal that's it we're [ __ ] any other
way do you see the fall five last night
yeah you see that picture yeah look at
your candy cane yeah that's human beings
each one of those cars has about four
anywhere from two to three people
probably or one person that's even worse
yeah we need japanese sex robots anal
those are only hope anal japanese sex
robots and you might not like it but
that's true i am i know i'm not most of
you like what and I'm financially
conservative I am NOT I am [ __ ]
Democrat socialist I don't give a [ __ ]
which is capitalism with some [ __ ]
parameters that [ __ ] rich people
don't go [ __ ] nuts on everybody and
we spread it around do we spend 13
trillion dollars on war mention we took
all that put it back into the country oh
yeah we'd be [ __ ] we'd be all have
flying cars and japanese sex robots yeah
yeah be much better totally that's what
I'm into so that's who I am so and
that's another reason why Canada is so
nice they don't have to worry about
having the military they don't to put
their money into military because they
got an 800-pound gorilla next door it's
kind of like having like evil Superman
as your neighbor if you know someone's
it breaks your house Superman's gonna
come over and whoop some ass anybody who
[ __ ] with Canada which nobody wants a
[ __ ] kara is like the koala bears of the
world yeah everybody likes them even al
Qaeda's like
canadians hockey too much but i like
them right there like that's why you go
through here like their security you go
through their security and they're like
really Pat you down it's like you're
Canada nobody hates you a couple crazy
guys get mad because their team lost the
[ __ ] Stanley complete flip a car that
is it like when I was in Canada wherever
I stood was the bad section in town
that's why I realized I was like the
shadiest guy in Edmonton wherever I
stood teenage pregnancy went up [ __ ]
theft went up illiteracy went up FL her
I stood as I was ma'am so I got go neck
Garnett comes he gets us these tickets
he's like re couldn't make it because
he's that anything is special and so we
go to game I Drive down I get them up
early I love telling Canadians when we
go to like any section go listen they
don't tell you the [ __ ] in the trial
Bureau or anything like that we're going
to a bad section of town okay you don't
make eye contact with any ethnic people
if you look they look at you you look
away because they'll [ __ ] shanky bro
I love scaring Canadians tebow said the
funny sing in the world on the right
over there T was like Americans are the
Canadians what black people are two
Americans look at this we scare the [ __ ]
out of them that's the best [ __ ] line
I've ever heard so I like to scare at my
friend cuz i had my friend jerry d and
he's like I'm American I love everybody
then we went to Oakland to do we can get
raped and like chill dude everybody's
cool we just lay down just don't yell
any hile Hitler's in the mill here or
talk about burning crosses and
everybody's good buddy just wants to
[ __ ] and smoke some weed drink some beer
get their dick sucked and have a laugh
that's that's the world dude that's the
world everybody's just laid back some
people are wearing this poor people they
gotta survive you know but I mean for
the most part the world is pretty chill
so anyways we go there we're walking to
the stadium who do we see Sen dog from
are insane in the membrane Cypress Hill
he's sitting there by himself no they
say nothing he just
like another Mexican at a [ __ ]
basketball game I'm like holy [ __ ] I
walk up we take a picture boom boom boom
I'm like he's I'm like thank you dude
he's like nah man thank you I'm like I
have no clue what you're thanking me for
but I'm cool with that man and then he
just got mopped and we just walked away
so there's this guy when you go to a
sporting event there's like 18 ah
there's like a ton of people just
standing around wanting free tickets
like they're looking for a prayer like I
need a ticket if you got a ticket please
give me a ticket so re didn't go so I
was like just giving me a free ticket
and he's like [ __ ] now like that's
really weird that you wouldn't give a
guy a nosebleed seat tickets I'm like
whatever weird guy okay here we go the
crazies coming out we go in we get in
first of all it's it's free hat day oh
oh not just like any bomb ass hats nice
they're [ __ ] real i warm yesterday on
our punch John does a nice hat I'm out
my bunny Oh days like are you wearing a
free hand like yeah a pretty nice hat
yeah usually they're garbage they were
so I'm wear that out all the time it's a
nice hat Steve Ballmer's getting it so
we get these hats I go I I walk around I
go with my ticket I get another free hat
for Dana so I got two free hats nice I
got two free hat and I'm like okay where
our seats I'm like 300 why he's like no
dude we're 1080 my mom oh [ __ ] that's
why eating her right because you spent
probably 150 bucks on these tickets and
they're really close i'm like that's
amazing and do we had the best seats
this is how good our sheets were you're
from LA for not from la the LA mass guys
now Chuck the Condor who I love to death
nobody else like something they all
think he's a piece shed but my I love
them but before that it was clipper
Darrell clipper Dale was a black guy you
don't know what age he is he could be
anywhere from 34 to lie clearly 65 you
don't know and he wears a black red and
blue suit everything is clipper up he's
known as clipper doubt that is life the
Clippers try to kick him oh they're like
now you're [ __ ] never coming back
they had a mountain news he's crying
every
ones like [ __ ] that dude clipper nation
just went nuts they got him back was
that the old owner yeah trying to kick
out a black guy yeah course again you
know dude for an 80 old man who bangs
[ __ ] you're pretty judgmental
[ __ ] for real seriously dude you were
banging a Filipino black [ __ ] he's
that weird like you know they pass that
lawless a gaze go to marianna in America
and in California and they did the
research they found out most of people
who voted for were Catholic blacks and
Mexicans and I'm like that's crazy
because all the [ __ ] outside of
donut time are black and Mexican you're
voting against your own people this
podcast can get me in so much trouble
between between this hell Hitler [ __ ]
that you got me worried about that was I
was just pointing share the upper role
that's joking should I just do like this
now I can't even do I gotta do like this
I got to do my palms up actually yeah
you they can't see your hands in the
screen thank God thank God so we go
there and AH we go there a sitting in
front of us is a Kovalev you know that
is to boxer yeah the guy who just fought
Ward sitting his two rows and head of us
I'm like holy [ __ ] and he's helped with
a whole rushing crew he's got the whole
crew and let me tell you man Russians
have their hooker game on point and let
me tell you clipper games you know the
Clippers are doing well because there
were hookers everywhere just [ __ ]
lovely white got old guys who look like
they love cocaine and cocoa butter and
slaying in the Sun hang out with [ __ ]
dime pieces dude doc this one chick
walked with this guy who look like this
leathery israeli dude walked way he
looked like a leathery Israeli hair
stylist like he got a hooker but he
really doesn't wouldn't know what to do
with her because he's not into that [ __ ]
and do they sit right next to us and
this girl's ass is I mean dude is so hot
and it goes right past Tebow's face and
he doesn't even look at cuz he's
concentrating on the game too much he's
a fan he is i'm a fan too
but dude when you see a [ __ ] legit
dimepiece ass you got to stop and show
some love if I beer I would have poured
it out out of respect just a little dip
a little boom boom a little love for
your ass so he coveops hasn't wrote this
guy the six year old guy comes with this
20 year old I mean dude smoking hot
russian chick and you got be honest I
think russian hookers are like the
Michael Jackson Michael Jordan I think
russian hookers are the Michael Jordan
of hookers they're like the pinnacle
because they're like first world hot
with a third world attitude like they're
the Russians are like the [ __ ] the
ghetto of white people like they don't
[ __ ] around they'll shoot they'll shank
somebody they don't give a [ __ ] Russians
don't give a [ __ ] that's all them
[ __ ] Russians they ain't afraid to
die for this [ __ ] much respect to the
rushing like I see Russians I dude i
watch sopranos you don't [ __ ] with
Russians this chick was so hot when
she's with this like 55 year old guy and
let me tell you somethin bout Russian
man they don't give a [ __ ] about age
difference Russian guys like I'm 55 you
are still in love with grit finish
homework then work my balls they don't
care they don't care Russians get it I'm
losing everybody I'm losing everybody on
this thing so the hooker game is on top
the right now the I've been going to
clipper games since 2000 and let me tell
you there is a complete difference
between those games and what the game
experience is like now there is nothing
but pyrotechnics on everything I mean
the hack game is on point I mean a
brand-new clipper hat gorgeous free and
now they got a t-shirt bazooka gun like
we have militarized her t-shirt case
like t-shirt cannons that's how much the
military-industrial complex has taken
over this country we have militarized
t-shirt guns that shoot like a thousand
guns like a million times like
they laid guns like just like like World
War two foot is like straight in the
crowd yeah just killing people Wow like
you invade countries with this [ __ ] now
we got it shooting t-shirts at everybody
and people go nuts for t-shirts people
nuts for free [ __ ] at stadiums it's
unbelievable it's crazy doing they're
the worst t-shirts now I don't know I
didn't get why I got one from way back
in the Donald sterling days and it's
literally sure I used to wash my car
with but these things might be on point
because these hats were on point not
this Raider how obviously but my clipper
hat and it's so funny because I'm a
Raider and I'm clipper fan and by the
way the Raiders and Clippers combined 13
and no on the road does anyone care
sailing care no I do and it's so funny
because i'll do the road and people like
oh you got sports podcast on my gastly
who your teens are Raiders and Clippers
band where I get I'm like dude you
should talk to me 2005 when I was two
weeks that in every season and I was
already over it these are the glory days
for Sam Tripoli sports team yeah these
are the glory we were like two games
away from going to the world series the
Dodgers you know kidney so you're st.
Louis fan are you saying loose on
everything or just baseball just
baseball how'd that happen have we
talked about McGwire home run chase got
me into the team like I learned they
were always on TV so I got to see him
but you were never a Padres fan and 98
when they went to throw series I know
you always Tony Gwynn you know I where
Tony Gwynn sunny way no talk like this
listen we gotta move the book the key is
to hit the gaps mm-hmm you ever listened
to his son dude Dodger talk know him in
uh David bouce or whatever his name is
I'm 570 out here they just argue that
the other guy is such a Dodger Homer
when Tony Gwynn Jr just tries to talk
fact they like they get in fights he's
like okay Tony watch it yeah I'll get
maybe I love the Dodgers like I did was
like dude you are such a [ __ ] Homer
it's annoying so anyways
he can and gun it was great dude took
pictures with Kovalev with a sundog from
I mean dude there was i got in the
jumbotron I was all Clippard I go
clipper game I'm a clipper Homer dude I
i got my clipper jersey i got from the
nice people out in toronto my 420 jersey
with my name on the back am i but he
said the only way he knew it was me
because he saw my name on the back of my
jersey people coming up like 420 man was
that mean I go with the [ __ ] wait
here you Clippard algos was 420 me I go
clipper Darryl you [ __ ] it's 2016 you
don't know what for 20 years what are
you [ __ ] it's weed I don't even
smoke it but sweet so I got in the
jungle trying to clip her hat on clipper
Jersey Cooper everything I've started
doing robots boom on a Jumbotron my
friends like my buddy who saw him is
like I can't get away from you you're
[ __ ] everywhere but yeah the military
I mean dude it was off a crazy gun a
crazy t-shirt gun all right so our real
quick I got two things I want to talk
about I want to talk about North Dakota
and the Standing Rock and the knave
Americans protesting and how they're
using military they're using like
concussion grenades against American
citizens like I just gotta talk I mean
really quick I know none of them
probably listen this podcast but if
you're a police officer and you are
using military force against American
says what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
like did you join the force to crack
skulls like this I mean like I even get
like wanna be it be in your neighborhood
and and cleaning up your neighborhood
and if there's some riffraff [ __ ]
lines of people up I can understand to a
point this has nothing to do this like
when you were a kid and you watched
movies did you dream of being the bad
guys like right now like you're the frat
guys from Revenge of the Nerds you're
the you're the [ __ ] from the Cobra
Kai
you're the one yelling sweep the leg
johnny right now you're an extra from
the karate kid movie rooting for the
Goldberg I when you watched Star Wars
did you dream of being a stormtrooper
cuz that's what you are you dream it you
are a storm trooper everybody else will
be luke maybe Yoda maybe han Solo did
you dream of being a stormtrooper I just
a [ __ ] another warm body for the
[ __ ] Empire to crack on the
resistance I mean that's what you're
doing you're not serving your neighbor
this is not protect and serve this is
higher gunship in our country man you're
using concussion grenades on US citizens
like I don't give a [ __ ] where you stand
on that pipeline this use of force is
uncalled for this is not a crime this is
not a terrorist attack this is US
citizens fighting for their own land man
you're on the wrong side of history
right now no matter how this goes and it
will not go up this I'm telling you
right now I will I can I will be shocked
if this pipeline goes forward the way
keeps mounting more and more and the
more force you use and what happened to
the stormtroopers my friends what
happened to the stormtroopers in every
so our movies they get killed they even
my Ewoks even by [ __ ] little 3e walks
kill song troopers to Darth Vader give a
[ __ ] Darth Vader give a [ __ ] about the
stormtroopers didn't give a [ __ ] about
stormtroopers man that's you dude that's
you you signed up to protect and serve
and now you're cracking skulls for the
Death Star and you know if they don't
give a [ __ ] about you and at the end of
the day man at the end of the day it's
your water to your kids water to your
[ __ ] environment so they so you're
doing all this evil [ __ ] for a paycheck
and a retirement fund which most likely
the way things are going is
even gonna be there when you get to that
age so you're selling your soul for a
[ __ ] paycheck and not doing what you
when you were kicked you dreamed up when
you are Katie dreamed of being a cop you
wanted to walk to be you want to keep
your neighborhood safe and you want to
treat people with some dignity because
you cared about your neighborhood this
is not it man this is you [ __ ]
cracking skulls against your own [ __ ]
people at the end of the day you're
going to be the one that has shitty
drink water a shitty environment and
you're gonna [ __ ] realize you got
using abused and the best thing you
[ __ ] do is either walk away from
there or turn into that badge and go
because right now you look like a
bouncer who passed the psych test and
got a job to [ __ ] hurt his own people
and it looks [ __ ] stupid and it's
[ __ ] wrong even if you don't agree
with the what the guys are doing hurting
your own [ __ ] people don't you watch
movies you're on the wrong side of the
story this was a movie in a theater
people be rooting for you for dying man
they be rooting for you to [ __ ] die
they would clap when you get shot people
clap for the [ __ ] song tubers to get
[ __ ] off man to [ __ ] it you're on the
wrong side of the story you're on the
wrong side of the story man and it makes
me [ __ ] sad because I know my my
father was grandfather my father who was
a grandfather my father was a cop and I
know he wasn't perfect when we went to
his funeral one side of the fourth one
side of the memorial was all cops the
other side was all the Niagara Falls mob
but my [ __ ] grandpa walked with some
honor you know and he wanted to do well
but man you're on the wrong side did and
I hope you find in your heart to [ __ ]
leave there man cuz you're gonna lose
this battle and you're gonna look at
kids in the [ __ ] thing go yeah I was
there and I was an [ __ ] you're the
guy in the [ __ ] grainy film of the
dude with the hose hosing down black
people trying to get him off the [ __ ]
off the sidewalk you're the one who
[ __ ] told rosa park to get the [ __ ]
off the bus that's who you are right now
you're on the wrong side man it's time
to go pick right you know how this ends
because it ends all
all the time the same way common sense
right what's right what's wrong and
what's right is that these guys have a
right to do what they want their own
land we have the right to clean water
with the right to an environment we have
the right to renewable energy and your
bar the [ __ ] problem and you're not
doing the job that you sign up for so
that's where we're at it's [ __ ] fake
news ass [ __ ] I'm dealing with right now
nobody's reporting this stuff watch the
nightly news you see anything about
North Dakota you see ya maybe sometimes
seeing em once in a while CNN's got
[ __ ] problems man this whole fake news
thing that's going on this is such
propaganda [ __ ] it's such propaganda
[ __ ] it's making up a term so you no
longer trust any other source except for
them 66 groups own all the news man the
messages bought so the sit there and
call people like democracy now who had a
reporter who got arrested for covering
the [ __ ] North Dakota pipeline
incident she got arrested she had to go
to trial the judge was like dude this is
too much through the through the charges
out but that's who's [ __ ] that's
that's real news The Young Turks real
news aw Jimmy shores that his name Jimmy
shore to me door Jimmy door jimmy dore
have you watched his show on youtube
phenomenal it's an excellent show that's
real news as crazy as Alex Jones is I
trust more than what he's saying then a
nightly [ __ ] news man I'm sorry I
know he's a piece of [ __ ] but sozin Don
Lemon Don Lemon is a piece of [ __ ] him
and bill o'reilly the same thing man
they're just different coins talking to
different groups I kind of like to see
Don Lemon get as crazy as Alec Jones
though that'd be kind of fun well you
know it'd just be Queenie just get
snarky yeah be be pretty hilarious
though I hope whoever [ __ ] down lemon
and ass really wrecks that [ __ ] just
[ __ ] gets air and drops dick on that
[ __ ] like Jimmy Snuka just [ __ ]
from the top rope and that guy can't
[ __ ] right for a week I can't stand Don
Lemon he's snarking he's what's wrong
with the
[ __ ] media he's a piece of [ __ ] him
Bill O'Reilly they're all piece [ __ ]
Alex Jones is a [ __ ] whack job crazy
guy but the problem is now he's on like
he's like the truth is like this [ __ ]
going on and nice comes off like a
racist dude Hillary clever ething you
don't like about Trump there's a video
of Hillary Clinton Bill Clinton saying
or doing the exact same thing that's my
point these people who are protesting
you're just begging for Frank Underwood
to cut from [ __ ] house the cars to
come save you she is a Sith Lord man she
that's look at her look how old and
decrepit the [ __ ] Clinton's look they
look like [ __ ] their souls are
draining he's a piece of [ __ ] man
[ __ ] Donald Trump is an orangutang
[ __ ] but the notion that the other
side would have anything better the
difference between Trump the difference
between Hillary is your hearing all the
evil [ __ ] that trumps doing if it was
Hillary they would never tell you that
this guy's part of monsanto's or walmart
or [ __ ] Glencore or any of these
other rothschild [ __ ] you wouldn't hear
it that's the difference all right we
gotta wrap up can we just real quick
okay I want to can we just talk about
Kanye has gone crazy if you listen to
the to the three or four or five
thousand people that listen this podcast
if Kanye is coming to your town do not
buy tickets for his show it is not good
old Kanye is dead we have lost him he is
gone he's dead and gone dead and gone
and we blame no one else but the soul
suckers soul stealers Kardashians I want
the seriously between rappers and pro
athletes I mean I'm surprised black life
matters having protest Kardashians for
all the [ __ ] black entertainers
careers they've killed their [ __ ]
serial killers where's Reggie Bush yeah
where's that light skinned black guy
that played [ __ ] wide receiver for
the cow
boys what's his name I can't he's gone
to Boston yeah where's Mike Austin gone
what miles miles austin where's he gone
lamar odom gone kris humphries gone
they're all gone dad in God Odell
Beckham went crazy gone they're all gone
their crate dude I mean dude when is
jesse jackson gonna step in and do
something he's God put an end to this
black serial killer [ __ ] huh I mean my
god there's sun enters sickle cell area
do something Jesse god damn it I mean
dude everybody's picking on Kanye and
Kim you guys don't know how traumatizing
it is to fake a robbery the minutes they
put into nothing this thing out and for
all that the crash and burn because
they're too [ __ ] retards it's like
that's traumatizing done good thing
about this whole crash burn is the porn
parodies gonna be great I wish I wish
you would actually the porn parodies
gonna be the first time a porn parody
actually stars the people who happened
to i could see Kim Kardashian get them
trains ran on them by Lamar and miles
austin that's my fav all right everybody
needs to chill the [ __ ] out so guys
we're gonna end this I had fun that was
good i felt like i was kind of back into
my groove with that right so I'm gonna
we're gonna play this video real quick
it's a couple minutes then we're get out
of here guys if you're in chicago come
see me get with me dawg if you have
anything ever want me to rant i do it
every Monday I'm gonna have Vicki peza
on the show next week nice we have the
naughty show back in the saddle um so
here we go this is lone wolf bye let's
see if we get this
the wolf on the hill is never as hungry
as the wolf climbing
it's not easy going it alone but if you
keep going stay true to yourself
it will be worth it in the end
the hardest won't you can make is the
walk you make alone but that is the walk
that makes you the strongest that is the
walk that builds your character the most
to all of you fighting battles alone to
all of you going against the grain
battling the naysayers stay strong keep
going
stay strong keep going this walk is hard
but the hardest walks lead to the
greatest destinations the toughest
climbs always lead to the best views it
will be worth it in the end and if you
show what you are made of the right
people will show up in your life you
won't be alone wolf forever
you have qualities only few can admire
because most don't possess
you have strength only few can
understand because most have never
experienced so don't give it don't
settle don't lower your expectations
defend till the world you are going to
stand out
you were born to eat leave the back
they say the wolf on the hill is now
or climbing the hill
always be that wolf climbing the heel
always hungry for more always hunger to
grow to feed your mind and rise to the
highest level
you can take yourself never looking back
always looking forward to the next feast
be some success in whatever you do
it does not matter if you have to walk
alone for a while
it is much better to walk alone in the
right direction than to follow the herd
walking in the wrong direction
stay strong be different
your destiny is in your needs get out
there and want it